February might be the shortest month of
the year but Netflix still has a long
list of new offerings coming your way
whether you're craving amazing action or
dizzying drama there's something for
everyone from horror to hilarity it's
all here for your viewing pleasure in
February looking for some action you've
come to the right place beginning
February 1st you can check out Dirty
Harry the 1971 film that first
introduced us to Clint Eastwood's iconic
detective you know the one you could ask
yourself question
do I feel lucky the 1967 classic the
Dirty Dozen is also coming to Netflix on
February 1st it tells the tale of 12
death row convicts who improbably become
soldiers infiltrating a Nazi powwow just
before d-day co-team if you're looking
for all together lighter fare there's
always the other guys a buddy cop film
starring Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg
who in a minor case unearths a much more
serious crime - down on their luck cops
realize they have the perfect chance to
prove their mettle here's a tantalizing
taste of what these down-to-earth crime
fighter's can do she's got the Golden
Goose now
[Music]
the other guys start streaming on
February 1st cravings sci-fi served with
a side of satire Starship Troopers will
surely hit the spot
directed by inscrutable Dutch
provocateur Paul Verhoeven the film
involves an all-out war between Earth
and a bunch of extraterrestrial bugs but
it also serves as a fantastic military
satire this underrated gem really piles
on the gore and hammy acting did we
mention the alien insects Starship
Troopers hurdles your way on February
15th fans of Blade Runner will
definitely want to check out Ridley
Scott's final cut yes it's one of just
many versions of the film but this is
the only one where Scott had complete
creative control over every frame the
sci-fi opus starts streaming on February
1st if you've never seen it before
here's your chance so run don't walk
there's so much gut-wrenching drama
coming to Netflix in February so go
ahead and consider your world
effectively shattered first up Roman
Polanski's The Pianist starring Adrien
Brody based on a true story it involves
a classical musician who manages to
survive the Holocaust against incredible
odds the film which won three Academy
Awards hits the streamer on February 1st
then there's Driving Miss Daisy the 1989
drama starring Morgan Freeman and
Jessica Tandy it depicts the burgeoning
friendship between a headstrong widow
and her supernaturally patient chauffeur
the film won four Oscars including Best
Picture and it's coming your way on
February 1st last but not least princess
semi-autobiographical musical drama
Purple Rain also starts streaming on
February 1st it tells the story of a
fiery young musician whose band is about
to make it big the film deservedly took
home an Academy Award for the score
which features let's go crazy when doves
cry and the epic title track here's an
icebreaker for you do you like the
police academy movies
if so February is officially your month
7 installments of the comedy series are
coming to the streamer on February 1st
and while you're at it why not throw in
scary movie - and a haunted house into
the mix they start streaming on February
1st and February 21st respectively
here's a little teaser for you
was it your furniture cast sex in the
city to also start streaming on February
1st then it goes a little something like
this what do you think this is fabulous
[Music]
who's her long-distance provider want to
see something really scary take a good
long stare at Polaroid which tells the
story of a high school outcast who
discovers an old camera but there's a
catch
anyone photographed by the camera comes
to a very grisly end say cheese
you can start streaming and screaming On
February 9th
then there's the girl on the third floor
the story of a man who just wants to
remodel his new home and live happily
ever after with his blossoming family
unfortunately this house was born bad
and it's out for blood check it out
beginning February 22nd finally there's
every time I die which has quite the
mind-melting plot after a man meets an
early death his consciousness keeps
zipping into the bodies of his close
friends turns out he's hoping to protect
them from the same person who killed him
will he succeed find out for yourself
and the movie starts streaming on
February 25th as for TV offerings were
super excited for the first season of
lock-and-key
based on the critically acclaimed comic
book series written by Joe Hill expect
lots of near indescribable weirdness our
favorite kind you can give it a whirl On
February 7th on the comedy side there's
only one new stand-up set coming to
Netflix in February 2020 but it should
be quite the doozy
on February 4th veteran comic Tom Papa
drops his fifth set of all new material
you're doing great for the uninitiated
here's Papa talking about his daughter
we have a mean girl yeah I didn't know
they were real I feel guilty I made it I
beat it I'm keeping him alive check out
one of our newest videos right here Plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]